I am determined to be a millionaire a
millionaire not in terms of dollars but
in terms of impacting millions of lives
I was personally challenged and I
I cannot imagine seeing people
challenged in the same way in this 21st
century because we have a solution and
we have a capacity to solve this problem
in our generation
when I was a little boy I could still
remember those days when I could see
worms in my poop really wimps and it was
just like common and I will see some
children dying of my age those days
we sell our water filter around ten
cents Lita compares to their commercial
bottled water which is around 50 cents
per liter so it is something like three
four five times cheaper
safe and clean water